und wir wollen der heutigen sitzung auch
noch mal ganz kurz in unserem überblick
verschaffen über die verschiedenen
positionen die es gibt wenn man über das
böse oder die sünde spricht wir haben
dann ein paar leitfragen gehabt die
augustinus betrafen wir hatten viele
dieser fragen das letzte mal bereits
behandelt was sind die motive der sünde
inwiefern können wir nach augustinus das
böse des bösen willen tun denken sie
zurück an dieses birnen beispiel das
augustinus sagte er hatte die birne
nicht deswegen im alter von 16 jahren
gestohlen weil er hunger hatte oder weil
die birne so attraktiv erschien sondern
weil es ihm einfach nur um das stehlen
der birne als solches gehen
es ging um das übertreten des siebten
gebotes glaube ich nicht dass sollte
stehen ist glaube ich sind das gebot
ging es darum dieses gebot zu verletzen
das wahrsagen
das motiv also man könnte sagen kein
objekt orientiertes motiv es ging nicht
um ein bestimmtes gut die birne den
apfel usw
es ging um eine formale struktur eine
formale struktur die eben nichts
konkretes mehr betrifft sind allgemeine
gebote oder verbote zum objekt hat das
also eine potenzierte sünde könnte man
sagen nicht so eine kleine kleine
lässiges sünde oder so ein kleiner
lapsus sondern es ist sommer die sünde
als sünde
deswegen ist das eine ganz wichtige
position wir hatten gesehen dass ich
solche formen des bösen oder der sünde
häufig jetzt in der neueren literatur
zeigen also der aufklärung beginnt damit
die saat oder auch weiter noch bis ins
20 jahrhundert wenn sie an besonders
böse figuren denken die handeln nicht
mehr unbedingt konkret auf ein objekt
gerichtet sondern die sind schon fast
metaphysisch böse und da findet man in
interessanten ansatzpunkt woran liegt
der grund des bösen diesen fragen wird
die jetzt noch kommen wenn wir uns ganz
kurz noch zu wenden weil wir eben seine
zweite schrift die wir uns vorgesetzt
hatten diese schrift über des freien
willens vermögen das letzte mal nicht
mehr behandeln
kunden wie sie weiß jeder von ihnen noch
was eine prävention sind eine perversion
theorie des bösen ist weil das sind
jetzt begriffe die immer wichtiger
werden mit denen wir unsere theorien die
wir lesen werden was die sünde betrifft
was das böse betrifft kategorisieren
können also unser ziel ist es mit den
ersten sitzungen mit dem sündenfall
sündenfall geschichte und jetzt mit
augustinus sind art koordinatensystem zu
entwickeln verschiedene
begrifflichkeiten mit denen sie dann die
jeweiligen texte kategorisieren können
einordnen können weiß jemand von ihnen
was eine privat ions these des bösen ist
schreibt mal hierhin privat
privat ions theorie was steht denn da
drin prävention überlegen sie mal hier
[Musik]
denken sie mal an privat so war es auch
wie privat
was ist denn bitte
genau
also fangen
andere klassische weil genau es gibt
noch eine andere interpretation dieser
präventionszug oder dieses gedankens der
sich in diesem mangel äußert es ist
nicht nur ein mangel an guten seinem
mangel am sein
häufig wird das sein und das gute
identifiziert sie kennen das bei platon
die idee des guten die thronte über
allen anderen ideen die ist der science
kommt alles sein denn und steht jenseits
des seins aber solche begriffe wie das
gute und das sein werden ganz häufig in
sehr enger verwandschaft gebraucht
deswegen schreibe ich ihn lange des
guten und des 1 das geht dann in die
richtung des nichts auch die tendenz ist
hier zum nichts hince gravität zum
nichts hin und dann haben wir noch eine
perversion story so wenn ich sie jetzt
einfach mal
auch wieder vom wort kommen ja
ja das darauf läuft es auf jeden fall
hinaus er völlig richtig und überlegen
sie nochmal wie kann man jetzt das
begründen dass das böse eine eigene
macht hat die haben wir gesehen es ist
ein mangel
das böse ist hier so immer so ein
bisschen untergeordnet es ist mangels 1
ist ein defekt könnte man sagen es sind
effekt und jetzt überlegen sie mal wie
sie richtig sagten es ist jetzt
es hat einen eigenen status und wie kann
man den jetzt mit dieser perversion noch
eine verbindung bringen
ja
da waren sie wollten auch noch wasser
ich schreibe jetzt einfach mal
verkehrung man könnte auch eine
umkehrung das ist diese perversion
verkehrung des guten vielleicht und man
könnte auch noch sagen es ist jetzt
nicht etwas ontologisch de potenzierte
sondern es hat so was wir eigene
positivität positivität ist jetzt nicht
so zu verstehen dass das böse gut ist
aber es hat einen eigenen stand ich
könnte auch noch schreiben
eigenständigkeit es vielleicht mehr
eigenständigkeit als eigenständigkeit
der akt des bösen kann einmal so
verstanden werden dass man den grund des
bösen der bösen handlung oder was auch
immer an einem mangel versucht zu
erkennen dass man sagt gut da ist
einfach nicht genug gut vorhanden oder
da ist soviel nichts im spiel zu wenig
sein
das wäre eine möglichkeit diese frage
woher kommt das böse zu erklären eine
andere möglichkeit wäre dass man sagt
naja das böse lässt sich auf unsere
freie entscheidung zurückführen und in
der freien entscheidung sind wir zum
guten wie zum bösen gleich einmal
gleicher weise aktiv und weil wenn wir
im bösen weniger cent wären oder weniger
verantwortlich
als in guten dann wären wir darin auch
weniger frei man könnte es uns nicht so
sehr zu gerechnet werden also wir müssen
das ist jedenfalls die moderne sicht die
wir aber auch schon teilweise bei
augustinus finden im guten wie im bösen
gleichermaßen zu rechnen dass sein was
voraussetzt dass wir dieselbe selben
grad an freiheit in der bösen handlung
wie der guten handlung hatten so dass
eben nach manchen ansichten im bösen
jetzt kein mangel herrschen darf weil es
dann ein mangel
freiheit wer und der würde zu einem
mangel an zurechenbarkeit führen so dass
sie böse wir handeln führen würden wir
umso mehr und zurechenbar wären und das
ist paradox erscheinen im guten wie im
bösen gleichermaßen verantwortlich sein
zu müssen
peter du hast ne anmelden
gegen das böse als großes versagen
beschreiben kann ohne dabei sich der
variante des guten zu bedienen
also wenn man das hier in verkehr und
dann ist das die tiere betreiben die
eigenständigkeit und das finde ich nicht
in der theorie
die frage ist natürlich sehr moderne
fragestellung kann man das böse auch als
eigene eigenschaft ohne akzidenzen in
rheine substanz selbst ist eine sehr
wichtige frage hat von ihnen denn jemand
dazu gleich eine idee wie man sowas
beantworten könnt dass man also sagt das
böse wollen wir jetzt nicht mehr über
das gute definieren weil wir es dann
immer tendenziell privat eve nur
bestimmen können es ist halt nicht das
gute oder mangel an guten wie können wir
denn das böse so bestimmen dass es eine
eigenständigkeit behält gegenüber dem
guten haben sie eine idee
ja
er weiß das schlechteste regierung
unsere sicht fatal ist das gut ist
das wäre jetzt die normative bewertung
also sicherlich das gute bleibt das gute
und das böse bleibt das böse und das
böse ist nur im kontrast zum guten
normativ bestimmbar also von der
normativen definitorischen seite denke
ich ist das böse durchaus irgendwie vom
guten abhängig weil das gute der maßstab
ist an dem er das böse misst den wenn
man das von einer definitorischen seite
her sieht dann kriegen wir nur sehr
schwer eine eigenständigkeit rein weil
da müsst ihr das böse das gutes sein das
böse dasjenige was uns anzieht so hören
wenn wir jetzt aber nach der unter
logischen fragen wenn wir die unter
logische frage aufwerfen oder die frage
der handlungs theorie also der gründe
der motivation basis glaube ich dass wir
eine möglichkeit haben das böse so
darzustellen wie du es gefordert hat das
wäre eine forderung also das böse
positiv darzustellen und da war der
hinweis glaube ich ganz gut bei
augustinus dass man sieht es gibt
durchaus motive die nicht privat eve
sind wo wir nichts sagen das ist ein
mangel an willensschwäche oder ein
entscheidungsfindung sind wo wir
wirklich in uns motive finden wo man
sagen kann das böse was dadurch getan
wird das hat seine art eigenständige
position und das wäre eben so was wie
zum beispiel ich möchte mich nicht an
dieses gesetz halten dieses gesetz stört
mich das gesetz empört mich dieses
gesetz schränkt meine individuelle
freiheit ein
und dagegen rebelliere ich so ein motiv
also ein motiv scheint ein eher passiver
oder positiver begriff des bösen zu
grunde zu legen
verglichen mit einem anderen fall wo man
aus zu großer lust heraus oder zu großer
begierde die birne stil wo man sagt ich
gleich ich hab so ein hoher und ich muss
jetzt meinen antrieb nachgeben und jetzt
stehe ich sehr halt da könnte man sagen
bei diesem beispiel natürlich war es
nicht gut was getan wurde es wurde
gestohlen
aber da ist ihr sohn mangel des gut
willensschwäche unbeherrschtheit
fehlende tugend wäre mit diesem anderen
fall wo man sagt hennig stört dieses
gebot dass das provoziert mich und
deswegen halte ich dagegen jetzt noch
mal sehen
guter punkt sie würden sagen selbst sie
würden also sagen augustinus würden sie
das sagen augustinus dachte immer als 16
jähriger als er das böse tat er trägt
das gute eigene
genau genau das was sie meinen folgen
sie meinen ich halte deswegen böse weil
das gesetz mich empört und ich ist dann
so für mich rechtfertigen dass es nicht
das gesetz sein sollte dass man als ein
anderes gesetz an die stelle dieses
gesetzes stellt und das wäre aber doch
genau dieser punkt der perversion der
kehre ich genau dieses gesetz um
das ist eine spannende frage aber das
wäre unabhängig von der frage nach der
möglichkeit einer perversion des
theoretischen auffassung des bösen die
es gibt diesen extrem ich falls doch mal
zusammen wir hatten noch zwei meldungen
ich habe es nicht vergessen wir haben
sie nicht vergessen es gibt diese diesen
hier gibt es zwei sonderfälle in der
perversion story die auf diese jetzt
hingewiesen haben einmal das böse und
des bösen willen zu tun das ist
augoustinos birnen diebstahl
das ist extrem provokatives böses oder
selbst noch unter dieser theorie der
perversion story das böse nicht um das
bösen willen zu tun aber das böse so zu
tun dass es aus einer empörung gegen ein
gesetz stattfindet und man das gesetz
auf den kopf stellt und rechtfertigt das
ganze noch also letztendlich sich eine
andere weltsicht konstruiert in der die
eigene handlung als gerecht erscheint
obwohl sie es nicht ist also eine art
von rationaler selbsttäuschungen belügt
sich aber nicht aus einem mangel heraus
sind aus einer richtigen kriminellen
energie heraus also man könnte hier
immer noch die perversion story sehen
jetzt hatten sich aber noch zwei gemälde
ganz hinten sie
und dann war noch hier eine meldung
bitte
hmm
die unter logische schweren bösen das
gute wäre sozusagen
[Musik]
autoren die wir jetzt haben sehr strenge
reinzukommen keine beweise
aber dann denkt doch mal die erbsünde
die erbsünde die mit augustinus schon in
spiel kommt oder bei kant aber das dann
später der hang zum bösen wir werden das
mit seinem hang zum bösen zu tun
bekommen der jedem menschen die hair and
ist unlauter
dann gibt es noch diesen pessimismus bei
schopenhauer das geht dann so ein
bisschen die diese richtung dass man
sagt wir sind eigentlich die welt ist
schlecht dass es diese klimatische
situation also auch noch eine gute
option jetzt hatten sie noch mit oder
es gibt eine eigenständige irritiere der
realität des bösen und die manifestiert
sich in akten wie hass neid usw
und die sind analysiert war ohne dass
gute irgendwie vor augen zu haben
definitorischen oder ökologische ja wenn
man das würde mit dieser erbsünde
durchaus finde ich gut zusammen passen
diesen premier diesen post labs arischen
zustands ihren sich nach dem sündenfall
haben wir das böse irgendwie in uns hat
meinen augen auch in der sündenfall
geschichte eine gewisse positivität ist
lösen und es ist nicht nur ein mangel
des guten sondern das böse wird nach dem
sündenfall zu einem positiven
unausrottbaren bestandteil der
menschlichen existenz wäre jetzt meine
sicht also wir können die perversion
theorie im grunde genommen schon in dem
sündenfall der sündenfall geschichte
entdecken
also es wird eigentlich immer so zwei
seiten geben
bei allen theorien die wir jetzt lesen
findet sich nach meiner sicht eine
privat tiefer aspekt der ist immer
definitorischen gegeben weil die
allerwenigsten die ordnung von guten
böse bestreiten würden also normative
differenz was gut und was böse ist dass
das böse eben das nicht gute ist die
wird immer bewahrt aber diese handlung
theoretische unter logische auffassung
des bösen hat es jetzt eine
eigenständigkeit woher stammt ist wenn
es aus dem menschlichen freiheit stammt
dann hat er schon etwas positives in
sich heraus weil es eine mögliche
ausübung unserer freiheit ist von zwei
möglichkeiten zum guten wie zum bösen
darin steckt schon die positivität also
wir werden immer wieder auch solche
aspekte finden und ein ziel unserer
seminar sollte es sein jetzt aus
längerer philosophischer sicht immer
versuchen diese zwei aspekte aufzuzeigen
es gibt kaum eine theorie die nur eines
von beiden hat wie wir schon an der
sündenfall geschichte sehen können auch
bei augustinus finden wir schon so einen
ganz starken perversion theoretischen
aspekt dass wir also ganz wichtig und
jetzt komme ich noch zu einem
theologischen punkt oder wir kommen noch
zum theologischen punkt weil jetzt haben
wir hier die herkunft des bösen also bei
augustinus werden heute noch sehen er
fragt woher kommt das böse wir lesen
noch ein paar zitate und jetzt gibt
peter
wie du ja viel besser weiß als ich hier
einige antworten woher das böse oder die
sünde kommen kann
wir haben uns da so ein schema x gemacht
dass ihnen helfen kann die jeweiligen
theorien im größeren zusammenhang zu
verordnen also man kann jetzt sagen das
ist die oberste sache der grund des
bösen kann einerseits in aus gott selbst
stammen oder in gott selbst liegen
haben sie damit ein problem also was was
könnte das problem einer solchen theorie
sein dass der grund des bösen aus gold
feld stand oder in gott selbst liegt
könnte man doch sagen als wären denkt
möglichkeit
nein
ja
das ist gut genau also wir ich habe
jetzt mal damals geschrieben widerspruch
fragt sich aber es muss nicht sein also
nur wenn eben all güte notwendigerweise
zum gottesbegriff hinzu gehört der
mächtigkeit ist davon nicht betroffen
er ist immer noch an mächtig allwissend
auch nur eben nicht mehr gültig es gibt
ja diese drei gottes prädikate all
gültig allmächtig und allwissend und
wenn wir eben den grund des öls in gott
selbst verordneten dann hätten wir eben
ein gottes prädikat nicht mehr als gute
aber allwissenheit durchaus eine
mächtigkeit auch noch mit blick auf das
theodizee problem massiv benannt haben
als die frage ist widerspricht so eine
annahme den gottesbegriff viele würden
sagen ja gott muss notwendigerweise
gültig sein
also darf der grund in ihm nicht zu
finden sein was auch jetzt immer genau
grund hier bedeutet und zu finden sein
das müsste man natürlich noch genauer
analysieren also dass es eine
möglichkeit weiß von ihnen wer in der
geschichte der philosophie diese these
vertreten hat das der grund des bösen in
gott selbst litt
wir lesen ihn auch noch wir werden ihn
auch behandelt in diesem semester
es ist der schelling friedrich wilhelm
joseph schelling meinten sie dass auch
oder schelling ist es fichte wird man
nicht lesen ficht er hat ein bisschen
was zum bösen gesagt in seinem system
der sittenlehre aber wichtig graviert
dann zu dieser privat ions theorie hin
schelling denkt einen grund in gott der
das dunkel ist ein dunklen grund und
daher versuchte ihn herzuleiten also
schelling wird diesen weg gehen aber auf
eine sehr differenzierte weise also sehr
sehr kompliziert wir lesen das dann
schon jetzt haben wir diese option schon
mal geklärt jetzt gibt es eine andere
option nämlich das der grund des bösen
nicht aus gott stammt ja da kann man mal
kurz erholen was ist was wäre der grund
dafür so was anzunehmen so eine position
zu vertreten da warum das der grund des
bösen nicht in gott selbst liegen sollte
haben sie eigentlich schon implizit
gesagt jetzt mit dem die möglichkeit
dass der grund in gott liegt was wäre
denn eine motivation so war seine these
zu vertreten sozusagen der grund des
bösen stand nicht aus darf nicht
ausgestellte darf nicht in gott liegen
was wäre denn wenn er ihn gott liegen
würde
unter peter hast du eine idee aus
theologischer sicht was wären da das
problem
den körperlichen eigenschaften
widerspricht widerspricht dass das tempo
drin sein sollte das team auf den weg
was sie alles was kommt als negativ also
böse beschloss außerdem medien
die seite zu unterstellen oder sein
fehler im system hat er nicht geschafft
des wesens das wahrscheinlich über
alters geschrieben
das bedürfnis in der welt etwas noch
nicht
darunter steht kann weil es nicht so
weil in der regel was nicht stimmt und
das kann nicht welche schulen genau da
und da werden geht mir jetzt ein
beispiel also nicht aus gott da gibt es
weitere möglichkeiten wenn der grund
nicht um gott selbst liegt dann könnte
er einem dunklen bösen prinzip stammen
dem dunkel haben sie eine idee wie man
diese position and in der theologie
geschichte wie nennt man diese
lenkerinnen und lenker die der
auffassung sind dass das böse nicht aus
deutschland sondern aus einem bösen
prinzip oder einen bösen gegen gott
könnte man auch sagen ja
genau also wir hatten das letzte mal
dann so ein bisschen gesagt man weiß
nicht ob gymnastik und maniche listen
also man nicht ist muss habe jetzt auch
noch mal aufgeschrieben ob die
beeinflusst wurden gegenseitig bisschen
strittig aber diagnostika haben auch
seine helle licht mit der vogel
das
[Musik]
und auch wie gesagt im modernen filmen
immer dieses schwarz weiß denn es gibt
den guten bösen hält den bösewicht wobei
es neuerdings wo die tendenz gibt auch
in diesen action filmen wie bei batman
zum beispiel diese klare opposition
etwas aufzubrechen so dass der held
nicht mehr eindeutig nur gut ist also
die das kommt auch in bewegung immer
wieder diese starre opposition jetzt
können wir wie beim letzten punkt fragen
was ist der vorteil der nachteil davon
von so einer position was befriedigt sie
theoretisch und oder theologisch und was
nicht wo haben sie bedenken wenn man
sowas annehmen würde
ja
spielball
das spürt man orientierungslos
dagegen
die richtige seite entscheidet aber
es ist es bietet orientierung auch in
der welt wir haben da eine
personifizierung wir haben ähnliche
qualitäten ich habe es da mal kurz
gesagt der mann lief man nicht ist muss
der spricht vom bösen nicht nur im sinne
von solchen mächten sondern auch von
sinnlichen qualitäten als das böse ist
überwiegend schmeckt ganz entsetzlich
es hat richtig sinnliche lebensweltliche
dimensionen
genau da ist auch noch diese zahl astra
zarathustra ist ja in persien sehr
bedeutend und die es gibt noch die cera
tus trier es gibt die noch als kleine
religiöse minderheit im heutigen iran
zur oberster genau und die armani das
ist der gründer dieses manches muss es
der mann nie so heißt der nani und das
ist ein perser wohl gewesen der ich
glaube es war so oben sind in der nach
christlichen zeit der versucht hat zum
sind kritisch muss zu erreichen also
verschiedene religionen zu fusionieren
paar jahrhunderte nicht allzu viele
jahrhunderte nach christus aus dieser
gegend und der war eben ein ganz
prominenter religionsstifter der aber
das christentum schon aufgenommen hat
also synkretismus ist ist das stichwort
zusammenführung verschiedener religiöser
tendenzen money so heißt also es bietet
orientierung wenn man kann alles von
gott wegschieben nur was verlieren wir
denn in dem wir jetzt gottes prädikat
der allg bewahren was verlieren wir dann
im gegenzug genau also zumindest prima
vati oder für einen bestimmten zeitpunkt
haben wir gott nicht als allmächtig
präsent wie kann man das ganze auf lösen
haben sie eine idee wie kann man
versuchen jetzt angesichts eines solchen
tourismus das prädikat der mächtigkeit
gottes wieder reinzuholen
überlegen sie mal was für eine
perspektive müssen wir auf diese zwei
mächte werfen und vielleicht doch
letzten endes dieses prädikat der alten
an mächtigkeit retten zu können
ja das wäre eine möglichkeit
übrigens immer noch mal die
geschichtliche dimension wenn man jetzt
von einem kampfhund gut und böse spricht
wenn das ein länger wir während der
kampf ist man hat seine vision eine ent
perspektive auf das ganze wird dass man
sagt das gute prinzip wird sich am ende
durchsetzt aber es ist ein ganz ganz
langer kampf und wir menschen die wir in
der welt leben wir befinden uns noch in
dieser kampf phasen wo es noch nicht
ausgehandelt ist wer jetzt am ende
gewinnen das ganze hat auch eine stark
geschichtliche dimension und das gute
wird am ende siegen aber bis dahin ist
es noch eine weile hin und jetzt sind
wir noch in diesem kampf einbezogen
meldung
sie sehen es gibt immer vor nachteilen
man gewinnt ein prädikat wieder hinzu
man verliert aber im gegenzug eines hier
jetzt eben die richtigkeit
das ist also der mann nicht es muss und
jetzt gibt es eine weitere position man
könnte auch noch sagen das böse kommt
und das betrifft jetzt augustinus von
dem wir noch ein paar wenige zitate
lesen werden das böse stammt aus dem
freien willen des menschen das ist jetzt
da der vorteil sagen
der grund des bösen liegt nicht in gott
sondern im freien willen des menschen
das könnte man jetzt dagegen einwenden
erstmal und auf der anderen seite was
ist der vorteil an solche autos
nur verschoben sozusagen vermittelt es
ist nur vermittelt über eine
zwischenstation ja man kann sich fragen
warum hat denn dann gott den menschen so
frei geschaffen dass er das böse tut
aber was wäre der vorteil wie kann man
es irgendwie auch noch retten
also wie kann man irgendwie sagen er
habe in dieser willensfreiheit der liegt
gerade doch die möglichkeit das böse
nicht auf gott zurückzuführen
wie könnte man jetzt die freiheit zu
definieren so erklären dass gott darin
entschuldigt wird irgendwie
ja also wie gesagt hier gibt es noch
zwei möglichkeiten die bringe ich noch
kurz das böse könnte jetzt als hier gibt
es dann noch mal zwei möglichkeiten wenn
wir jetzt von freien willen ausgeht
könnte sagen das böse ist notwendig wir
kommen aus dem bösen gar nicht raus wir
brauchen eine erlösung durch gott und
jesus christus dass die erbsen lehre die
geht auf augustinus zurück und wir
werden auch sehen dass luther martin
luther den wie der nächsten sitzung
behandeln in seiner auseinandersetzung
mit erasmus von rotterdam dass der
gerade diese diesen punkt ganz stark
macht das dann aber auch so ein bisschen
bestreitet also der freie wille wird
problematisch aber diese apps finden
wäre ist sehr wichtig und da gibt es die
andere position die sagt das böse kommt
mit der freiheit ist wir uns ins spiel
aber die erlösung vom bösen ist ohne
gott möglich weil es jemand wie man
diese position nennt noch theologisch
das liegt mir wenn ich in unserer hand
ob wir von bösen uns wieder abwenden
können wir brauchen dazu nicht
notwendigerweise gott oder jesus
christus
das ist auch so ein schimpfwort gewesen
in der zeit luthers vielleicht auch noch
heutzutage ich kenne mich nicht so gut
aus
ja
diskriminieren möchte oder ein
schlechtes licht stellen möchte weiß
jemand mit p fängt der name an
pelagius plagiat
das ist nicht nicht plagiator sein hella
diana ist ganz egal also diese diese
zwei positionen sind auch noch ganz
wichtig für die nächste sitzung mit
luther luther vertritt die auffassung
dass wir uns aus dem bösen nicht aus
durch eigene kraft befreien können vom
bösen und planlos ist der meinung eine
macht diese freiheit sehr sehr stark
sogar die freiheit gegenüber gott
impulse
das ist natürlich eine position die uns
heutigen den meisten von uns heutigen
jedenfalls sehr sehr nahe steht die
meisten philosophen die eine these von
willensfreiheit vertreten wären pella
diana
sie werden vielleicht dann nicht
insofern keller gerne als versieht das
böse gar keine rolle mehr spielt der
begriff des bösen ist ja auch durchaus
problematisch geworden aber feinen
philosophen der das böse und die
freiheit zum bösen behandelt für den ist
in der mais in den meisten fällen ist
auch völlig selbstverständlich dass sich
aus der eigenen freiheit vom bösen auch
wieder abwenden kann
die bösen hin abwenden kann also dass
man ihnen ein plagiat schimpfen könnte
aber genug von diesen schimpfwörtern
also merken sie sich nochmal hier diese
ganze grob kategorisierung wo kann man
immer den jeweiligen denker den wir
behandeln die denkerin haben ja noch
hannah arendt dass am ende die kann man
nämlich her auch sehr schön verorten wo
kann man die hier vor ort wo gehören die
rein und dann auch noch angesichts
dieser kategorien sind sie eher anhänger
einer pensions- theorie oder einer
prävention szene jetzt haben sie sogar
nicht alle kategorien die sie im grunde
genommen schon im sündenfall finden
konnten in dieser geschichte ist alles
drin
postleb sarah spray japanischer auch
noch bedacht und das als hintergrund vor
dem sie dann die jeweiligen denker
ließen das ist jetzt das ziel unseres
seminars und jetzt haben wir hier ein
paar zitate aus der libero abi trio von
augustinus von freien willens vermögen
als augustinus nochmal ganz zurück der
sagt ich bin gerade das böse kommt
nicht aus gott sondern aus der freiheit
des willens und lieber um atrium ist
nichts anderes als des freien willens
vermögen über das freiwilliges vermögen
von augustinus wir beide stellen jetzt
noch ein paar zitate vor wir wollen dann
auch noch zu thomas von aquin übergehen
können ich lese einfach mal vor er sagt
wir pflegen auf zweifache weise von übel
mal um zu sprechen zum einen sagen wir
jemand habe etwas böses getan
zum anderen etwas schlechtes sei
erlitten worden das ist auch eine
unterscheidung die wir ganz am ende der
letzten sitzung noch kurz hier an die
tafel geschrieben hatten weiß von ihnen
auch mal jemand wie man das böse
dahingehend unterscheiden kann es gibt
da einmal um so und einmal so
zwei arten von malware
genau das gibt auch noch genau
das reicht jetzt mal für unsere zwecke
das moralisch moralische übel dass wir
jemand das was wir jemand anderem
willentlich an tun müsste man genau
genommen haben absichtlich antonio
morana moral und das malen physikern ist
die krankheit wenn sie irgendwie eine
krankheit haben die sie trifft dann
leiden sie unter einem natürlichen übel
einen physischen krankheit ist das beste
beispiel dafür
wenn sie aber jemanden jetzt in seine
suppe einer person die suppe eine reine
gift substanz mission dann haben sie die
beiden maler verwechselt oder verbogen
haben sie also durch ihre moral haben
sie einmal um physikum hervorgerufen
also das mal um moral äußert sich dann
auch in solchen natürlichen letztendlich
aber hier ist dann die absicht nämlich
im spiel die die willens gesinnung die
wir thematischen also wir werden es
eigentlich nur mit solchen maler zu tun
haben mit dem moralischen überall so
dass findet sich jetzt hier bei augustin
das eine ganz wichtige unterscheidung
und jetzt kommt dieses große problem hat
es sehr sehr klar erkannt er sagt wenn
die sünden von denjenigen seelen
herstammen die gott geschaffen hat diese
seelen aber von gott stangen wieso sind
dann die sünden nicht ihnen direkt das
war die argumentation der teilnehmerin
auf gold zurückzuführen
man hat halt gott menschen geschaffen
und der mensch tut was böses aber
letztendlich mittelbar über die
schöpfung kann das böse dann doch
eigentlich nur wieder gott zugeschrieben
werden was dann seine prädikat der alte
gesprächen wurde das ist das dilemma
woher kommt das das böse angesichts
allmacht gottes und alt gut gefallen
gibt es also einen anderen urheber des
jähnigen übels dass wir wissen nicht von
gott verursacht wird hier gibt es zwei
optionen überlegen sie sich noch mal
ganz kurz dieses schema welche zwei
optionen gibt es wenn das übel nicht von
gott stammt stammt kann von wem kann es
dann stoppen gibt eigentlich nur zwei
möglichkeiten
nach diesem schema überlegen sie noch
mal
genau also entweder man sagt man ich es
muss böse gegen gott daherkommt oder wir
sagen es kommt aus uns aber so aus uns
dass es nicht aus gott kommt das muss
man dazu sagen so aus uns dass es nicht
mittelbar auf gott wieder zurückgeführt
werden kann
aus unserer unhintergehbaren freiheit
sozusagen das wären die zwei
möglichkeiten
er hat er noch viel argumentation dazu
wir bringen jetzt nur so ein paar
wichtige zutat er argumentiert er
natürlich durchaus weiteres zitat nun
gut da du mich zwingst einzel gestehen
dass wir das böse du nicht lernen sag
mir wie es kommt dass wir böses tun das
ist diese grundfrage woher tun wir das
böse und male fakih amos male ist hier
nicht das böse tun so dass wir das also
nicht die richtige übersetzung weil das
adverb dass wir also böse tun genau oder
auf böse weise handeln
da wird das tun qualifiziert dass das
male ist nicht das objekt des tuns das
was wir tun wenn ich es recht saison
dass wir auf eine böse weise tun das als
1 abwehr zum zum fahrrad zum tun aber
letztendlich kann man genauso fragen
dass wir das böse tun
woher kommt das das ist die grundfrage
noch ein zitat vorsichtig ist ein leben
ohne furcht begehren nämlich nicht nur
alle guten sondern auch alle bösen der
unterschied aber liegt darin dass die
guten danach streben in dem sie die
liebe abwenden also die aversion von
jenen dingen die man nicht besitzen kann
ohne gefahr sie wieder zu verlieren die
bösen aber versuchen alle hindernisse zu
beseitigen um diese dinge in sicherheit
genießen zu können und deshalb führen
sie ein verbrecherisches und
schändliches leben also er hat das immer
was mit abkehr und hin kehrt zu tun auch
im guten wie verhalte ich mich zum bösen
es geht also um eine bewegung die
durchaus auch aktiv genannt werden kann
so eine art perversion theorie oder
aversion theorie der enthalten ist es
geht um bewegungen verhältnis
bestimmungen
und jetzt hier ist jedoch ein wichtiges
zitat da sie noch mal sehen woher jetzt
das böse kommt nach augustinus was dem
herrschenden und der tugend mächtigen
geist gleich oder übergeordnet ist macht
ihn der begierde nicht dienst war wegen
der gerechtigkeit was aber niedriger ist
vom markt ist nicht wegen der schwächen
wie unsere feststellungen zeigen bleibt
also nur dass nichts anderes den geist
zum genossen der begierde macht als der
eigene wille und die freie entscheidung
das ist ein sehr modernes eine moderne
auffassung es würden wir heute auch
alles unterschreiben
die freie entscheidung auch aus
juristischen gründen es muss immer
zurechenbarkeit gegeben sein
der mensch musste frei sein um ihn dann
verantwor verurteilen zu können ist die
grundprämisse
das ist nochmal dasselbe und jetzt auch
hier
es steht aber fest dass es am willen
liegt was jeder als zu erjagen des alls
zu erstreben des und zu gefangen das
wählt und dass der geist durch nichts
aus der burg seiner herrschaft und aus
der rechten ordnung heraus geworfen wird
als nur durch den willen es ist auch
klar dass nicht irgendeine sache zu
beschuldigen ist wenn jemand sich
schlecht gebraucht sondern derjenige
selbst die sie schlecht gebraucht wieder
ganz modern oder vertreter der
willensfreiheit man sagt auch augustinus
seit der erfinder des modernen willens
begriffs das sagt kanaren vor augustinus
gab es keinen richtigen willens begriff
sie wissen ja in der antike die antike
kannte so was wie willensfreiheit
eigentlich nicht gab es doch das
schicksal war sehr wichtig war
es gab zwar so ein strebe vermögen das
objekt ikon bei platon aristoteles aber
einen willens begriffen eigentlichen
sinne
den gab es nicht in dieser dreiteilung
der seele platon aristoteles haben eine
seelen teilung lehre die verschiedenen
stufen der seele bei platon gibt es das
etikett ikon das ist das begehren
vermögen das streben vermögen das aber
ihr triebhaft zu verstehen dann gibt es
das kino i des das ist das motiv der
botschafter willand willens zeil und
dann gibt es eben noch diesen oberen das
logistik aber der wille selbst kommt
darin nicht richtig zur sprache also
augoustinos vertreter erfinder wie
johanna anzeigt dass man deren willens
begriffs ja dann hier noch 1 und dann
haben wir glaube ich auch genug von
augustinus gehört der wille sagt oppers
der sich von wandelbaren und gemeinsamen
gut abwendet und sich den privaten gut
dem äußeren oder dem niederen zuwendet
zündet man kann jetzt natürlich wieder
hier schauen privates gut
ist da so eine mangel an guten im spiel
präventions- theorie kann man sich
fragen
auf der anderen seite sagt er ja der
sich zuwendet der als eine andere
ordnung herstellt hat man hier wieder so
ein moment der perversion wenn der werte
man wertet gut und böse um letztendlich
mehr streben
das noch eins das ich sehe das hier
beide theorien letztendlich enthalten
sind jetzt kommt eben die zentrale these
die wieder ein bisschen uns zu dem
nächsten denker für den thomas von
alpina sagte mich jetzt zum schluss hin
untersuchen alles gute aber stammt von
gott also gibt es kein wesen das nicht
von gott stammte jene bewegung der
abkehr die wir sünde genannt haben ist
eine bewegung zum mangel aller mangel
aber stand vom nichts
also würden sie jetzt nachdem sie diese
ganzen zitate gehört haben
als fazit sagen augustinus ist ein
vertreter der privaten story oder der
perversion steering und haben dieses
zitat was würden sie sagen ist nicht
ganz entschieden gibt es verschiedene
auffassung dass vielleicht noch zum
schluss bevor wir uns zur thomas von der
queen übergehen
alles spricht dafür ihn als ein privates
theoretiker zu lesen was dafür als ein
perversion stil wieder zu lesen
vielleicht auch zu banalen hat die
banalität des bösen
aber es ist nicht ganz klar also da
streiten sich die forscher wirklich
darum mich hat diese auffassung er jetzt
zuzurechnen gibt es denn ein signalwort
in diesem text was sie jetzt auf eine
dieser theorien besonders fokussieren
lassen könnte ein signalwort das kommt
da unten von da oben ja
genau man hat beides nahm sie sehen es
gibt ja beide moment es gibt eine
bewegung die aktiv oder positiv
vollzogen wird das ist ein bisschen so
was wie eine perversion story aber die
bewegung geht hin zum mangel das ist
also dann eine da liegt dann die
präventions- theorien aldi frage ist
jetzt aber die ist die bewegung zum
mangel selbst ein mangel oder ist sie
etwas positives also ist das ziel der
bewegung zum mangel hin ist das ziel so
verfasst dass es die bewegung selbst
agitiert also die frage die im zentrum
steht ist die ist die bewegung zu
mangeln etwas mangelhaftes oder etwas
positives etwas eigenständiges etwas was
für eine verkehrung vollzieht das ist
die frage
also erscheint hier irgendwie beides
zusammen zu denken
da
aktionen des begriffs nicht nennen wenn
das nicht ein etwas ist auch dass man
sich zu bewegen kann einfach theoretisch
sogar mit dem bösen ersetzen das böse
tauchte in dem zitat werden also er mal
nicht vom nicht statt sondern letztlich
vom bösen starten würden
attraktiv draufzulegen würde sehr für
den perversion wenn es nichts aber
eigentlich nichts ist dementsprechend
konnte sich auch nicht dazu bewegen das
nicht eigentlich nur die absolut gedacht
abwägung von der etwas anderen
gut genau genau guter punkt
er redet vom nichts jedenfalls einer
substituierten weise was ist so
behandelt wie ein objekt wie ein
erstrebenswertes objekt aber das könnte
man sagen dass widerspruch dass nichts
kann als solches gar kein
erstrebenswertes objekt sein
ihr seht ihr er schwankt hier irgendwie
zwischen beiden positionen
das werde bei ganz vielen denken noch
sehen dass es nicht ganz klar ist wo sie
jetzt intendiert ok mit dieser privaten
perversion theoretischen bemerkungen
lassen wir das mal winden mit augustinus
und gegenüber zum nächsten denker zu dem
wir heute schon ein referat gehört haben
nämlich zur thomas 100 wien und zwar
geht es hier um die summe gegen die
haydn und da geht es um ein paar kapitel
die vom börsenhandel und auch hier haben
wir wieder ein paar leitfragen und die
lese ich auch mal vor wie sollte es
anders sein inwiefern vertritt thomas
von aquin eine prima zions theorie
lassen sich bei ihm auch ansätze einer
perversion story finden
wie kann thomas und das kommt jetzt noch
dafür argumentieren dass das böse
zugleich unbeabsichtigt und der noch
willentlich ist diese these vertreter
nämlich auf seite 25 und weiter noch
inwiefern kann thomas behaupten dass das
gute die ursache des schlechten ist das
sind die fragen so jetzt können wir
einfach mal der reihe wieder vielleicht
lesen wollen wir mal gerade hier
beginnen wollen sie mal das erste zitat
lesen
vielen dank als hier ist doch jetzt
auffällig dass er jetzt über das böse
über den begriff des fehlers sich mehr
fehler es ist ein fehler ein lapsus
könnte man auch sagen
und jetzt geht es aber ganz konkret um
die frage nach dem anrechnen des fehlers
also der zu recht barkeit des fehlers
ich glaube wir können wir das nächste
start noch dazu nehmen sie es mir
einfach mal weiter in der 1
nein
vielen dank und jetzt müsste ihn sofort
hier ein problem dem man mit blick auf
das gute und das böse fand das böse wenn
sie sich mal den letzten satz jahren
schon als ist jedes tätige um alles
gutem willen tätig das kann man auf zwei
verschiedene weisen verstehen ja
genau
genau diese erste satz dass jedes tätige
auf etwas bestimmtes zu strebt und dass
jedes tätige um eines zieles will tätig
ist das ist von aristoteles übernommen
ist die theologie dieses strebens
strebens ethik alles genau alles
vollzieht sich nur kannst auch da hinten
noch schreiben wir haben also alles
kommt nur deswegen bewegung des handels
weil es ein gut gibt wohnung auf das hin
gestrebt wird abgezielt abgezielt wird
dass dieses genau die theologie das
tessin wie es jetzt beim bösen also man
muss sich jetzt fragen wie ist es wenn
wir was böses tun was uns ja zugerechnet
werden können muss streben wir dann auch
auf was gutes an bonum was passiert war
haben sie schon eine idee wir werden
auch gleich weiter lesen noch weitere
zitate finden aber wie könnte denn jetzt
man könnte man es darauf antworten ja
hmm
es ist nicht zu verstehen
das erste mal ersten alles in der welt
sehen und dieses leben ist in der welt
das böse sein wie sich einen bösen oder
einen nicht angemessen diese jeweilige
format überhaupt alles in der welt
passieren die unterschiedlichen aber
besser dass die angemessen sie haben
nicht die welt und für den menschen
bisher ohne weiteres nicht zu erkennen
welche bewegungen passen und welche
darin
das muss nicht sein drückt also in den
angemessen
die frage der thomas nacht
seinen feinschliff das braucht es eine
gewisse politische lebensleistung die
möglichkeit unterschiedliche varianten
dieser bewegung sei es zu unterscheiden
zu viel gleich hinter übertroffen
das problem ist glaube ich klar
also hast du glaub ich sehr deutlich
jetzt gerade erklärt wir können jetzt
mal das nächste zitat vielleicht noch
hinzunehmen
vielleicht nächstes mal
vielen dank
also da kann man jetzt noch mal hier
schöne sind 2
zwei theorien aber mit vergleichen
prävention und perversion story war
jetzt hier neuer begriff ins spiel kommt
der mit dem guten ganz eng verwoben wird
der grundbegriff der metaphysik
überhaupt was mit welchem anderen
wichtigen begriff wird jetzt das gute
plötzlich hier zusammengebracht
genau das sein
schauen sie mal auf die präventions-
theorie wir hatten hier ein mangel des
guten auch ein mangel des seins sein
inwiefern kann jetzt thomas von der
queen's sagen das was das jeweilige sein
ist ein gutes ist also wie denkt er sich
jetzt diese verbindung von sein und
guten nach muss das gute 11 sein oder
das seien ein gutes sein
hmm
hmm also wird sagen wenn es eine
bewegung nicht zum guten hin wohin wäre
dann wäre es eine bewegung zum nichts
hin oder zu etwas und zum seien würden
sie sagen das was existiert oder wie
würden sie das sein ist der samstag
immer was es unter dem sein zu verstehen
das was existiert und kann als nutzer
etwas hin streben was existiert
es werde mögliche lesart genaues sie
hatten sich noch mit
hmm
genau also mir auch böse bezogen das
böse würde eben dann wie wir schon bei
augustinus sahen am letzten zitat das
böse würde natürlich kein gut sein wäre
kein wohnung und es würde aber auch kein
sein treffen
es wäre das nichts betreffen und das
problem ist wie du glaube richtig
gezeigt hast dass nichts ist das jetzt
ein objekt ist es jetzt ein sein dass
wenn ihr vom nicht sprechen und
substantiiert es ist ja eigentlich eine
ökologisierung des lichts zugleich ist
es aber nichts also nicht sein dass
jetzt aber ich glaube sie haben völlig
richtig gesehen das ist eine strategie
um gott zu entlasten
vom bösen nachdem wir streben durch das
nichts
als das
da habe ich mich schnell deutlich
[Musik]
alles das was überhaupt möglich zu
erkennen sein
daran keine eigenschaften ermöglichen
auch eine münze ist auch diese sich
darin schon sieben prozent potenziell
ist eingestellt
was alles potenzielle daraus werden
könnte
das ist eine dass in dem sich das klar
dass es ein ziel hat
motive der sich an der anderen
gegenständen dann auch tut
unter den erscheint könnte irgendwann
klar erscheint dieses problem von gut
und böse einer gewissen weil es
zumindest legt thomas sie diese pferde
die frage werden wo ist denn das was man
böse das unangemessen bezeichnet zu
hause
ja
[Musik]
ein guter hinweis mit diesem entstehen
und vergehen
das ist ja der bereich des physischen
letztendlich das werden und vergehen und
bei platon haben wir schon die theorie
dass das eigentlich sein denn das
unvergängliche ist das was also ganz
konstant existierte sind die ideen beim
platz und es gibt dann die welt die
konkrete welt und dies aber im wandel
begriffen und bei kloten den wir leider
ja auch nicht blöd ihnen den wir leider
auch nicht hier behandeln können ist es
ganz ähnlich ein neuer platonischer der
auch das eine und das sein das
unveränderliche dem werden vergänglichen
endlich entgegenstellen und das auch vor
dem hintergrund der zuschreibung von dem
guten und dem bösen
es gibt eine tendenz das böse das mal um
den vergänglichen natürlich
zuzuschreiben dem was wird das nicht
konstant ist ne also noch ein guter
hinweis als ergänzung sollte vielleicht
noch ein zitat weitermachen um dieser
diesen fragen die sich jetzt hier
hingestellt haben um diesen noch weiter
nachgehen zu können vielleicht glaube
das ist jetzt genau jetzt kommt das
nämlich mit dem aktuell lesen wir
vielleicht noch weiter
ja
vielen dank ja jetzt haben wir die von
dir kurz erklärten kategorien des akts
der potenz man noch ein bisschen
deutlicher hier
und vielleicht können wir uns nochmal
der frage zuwenden wo jetzt das gute und
das böse in diesen verschiedenen modi
dass sein denn zu finden sind
ich habe etwas von meinem spiel er macht
ja das selber so ist immer für zb der
rede versucht man denken es ist
schwächeres anderes ausfällt machen wir
doch mal vorschlagen können beispiel das
programm könnte man das jetzt mal
konkretisieren
man kann diese sehr anschauliches
lebensweltlich und das sind das hilft
das schlechte ist dass prise kern über
aufbauen wo man dies unbedingt etwas zu
erkenntnis oder in diesem brief was
passiert was seine aktualität also seien
drin sein
nehmen wir zum beispiel haben
die frauen jetzt so verändern dass es
nicht mehr so ist und ich darf den
ersten die das leben kinder das ist
seine aktualität beschädigt es gebe gute
umständen zum menschen
einen schritt ist
na ja also ich finde dass ich finde dass
ich finde das eine ganz wichtige
unterscheidung zwischen 8 und potenz und
hier könnte man noch ein bisschen
fokussieren auf das was er sagt diese
aktualität verfehle also wieder der
fehler den wir schon gehört haben also
ein
ein abweichen im streben ein nicht
gerecht werden dem begriff dem wesen
hast ja auch gesagt und jetzt halt die
frage ob die gleich ob dieses verfehlen
diese stellas ob das selbst noch positiv
gedacht werden kann oder ob das nur ein
reines defizit ist reiner defekt rainer
langel mir scheint hier eine ganz starke
privat ions theorie vertreten zu werden
eine ontologische genau wie also das
gute gar nicht so sehr ins spiel bringt
da wird dem wesen nicht entsprochen wenn
etwas eigentlich auf etwas hin zielt ins
und auf etwas sein das hin zählt was
dann auch gut ist es ist erkennbar es
hat mir klare form auch noch ein
wichtiger punkt der form aspekt der ring
ist deswegen erkennbar und aktuell weil
er eine form hat die konkrete form und
wenn diese form verfehlt wird wie in
diesem beispiel jetzt dann hat das auch
auswirkungen auf das sein ist also wohl
auch eine ökologische implikation jetzt
hatten sie sich gemeldet wird
richtig also hier müsste man sich das
jetzt so vorstellen so denke ich dass
sie einfach keine form erreicht wird das
hier also die materie fühle stoff ganz
allgemein meint eigentlich sogar nur
holz als höhle ist die griechisch man
eigentlich nur bauholz zu holzmaterial
aber holz ursprünglich als aus dem
lebenswichtigen kontext holz aber
materie formbare materie dass diese form
also stelle ich mir das vor dass diese
form waren materie nicht in eine form
gebracht wird
in die sie gebracht werden sollte die
frage ist wirklich jetzt wie man das
versteht die aktualität verfehlen
also ist damit eine bestimmte aktualität
verfehlt also statt aktualität kann auch
sagen form eine bestimmte form wird
nicht erreicht wird steht erst eine
andere form erreicht oder eben keine
form und ich lese ist so dass keine form
erreicht wird das was amorphis ist und
das amorphe ist daneben und logisch
völlig de potenziert es ist eben nur die
materie in einer amorphen gestalt und
das ist natürlich gegenüber einer
materie die in form gebracht wird und
theologisch untergeordnet ist eine
gewisse presse so lese ich dass man
könnte aber auch sagen es wird eben die
aktualität verfehlt insofern eine andere
form hervorgebracht wird die nicht
intendiert war oder so und dann hätte
man eben ökologisch vollkommen
konzentriert das objekt bei aristoteles
spricht man immer vom süden hollands in
hollern heißt das zusammen ganze das
zusammen ganze aus form und materie
es muss als sie alles sein der hat immer
ein form aspekt oder eine form an formen
moment und ein materie moment und hier
könnte man sagen hier wird einfach die
form verloren hier verliert das streben
oder das objekt seine form
es ist am hof und weil es vom los ist
ist es eben unter logisch weniger sein
als
vollständig konstituiert das objekt wie
jetzt einbringen aber es wäre auch nicht
ganz nichts weil es wäre ja vielleicht
noch irgendwie die potenz oder die
materie die dann noch so irgendwie war
das sag ich jetzt mal aber eben halt
ontologisch unter untergeordneter das
ganze ja
ja wer denn dann steht auch verschiedene
beispiele seien von ist ein mensch der
keine ende das ja was man das früher
seien im regen an dem ding überhaupt
böse sein
hmm
das verwerflich ist so was meinen sie
dass das schlechte kann einfach nur
anlass zum ärgernis sein das ist
untauglich
das ist also fouls oder chaos oder sowas
die antiken kannten ja auch den begriff
des bösen so wie wir ihn kennen engeren
mussten immer sagen mahlow moralisch um
das böse auszudrücken mussten die antike
sagen mahlow moral
die hatten gar keinen einzelnen begriff
dafür
es gibt ja noch die hamas die sünde das
ist dann ein ein einzelner begriff aber
das moralisch böse oder das böse
wir würden ja auch an der krankheit
nichts sagen dass es was böses würden
sagen was schlecht ist wenn wir sagen
dass es böse haben einen ganzen land
moralisch kommentierten begriff während
hier
augustinus immer sagen muss einmal um
ein moralisches marburg also das böse
als solches kommt nur ganz selten
isoliert vor immer sehr eng verbunden
mit verschiedenen effizienz form mit
einem weiteren zimmer
letztlich erst mal ernst ganz einfach
der die frage stellt warum lässt sich ja
einfach beim schlecht dazu braucht man
überhaupt eine vermutung wäre jetzt das
einfach die ganze aller paris tätig wo
ist als giftig werden wenn das was sie
sich unter dem dem aktuell die vorstände
das sind irgendeiner form gefahren das
war eine viel größere katastrophe als
nur das varianten stehen ist das nicht
schön ist in dieses große rolle also
schön schön im boot sind ganz einfach
nicht mehr nützlich ist wie du eben
gesagt dass alles da könnte man immer
noch sagen herne guten alten aber viel
schlimmer alter geschlecht ist wenn die
aktualität ist rings bedroht wenn der
ring nicht mehr in frage
dann wird es ganz ganz ganz fundamental
diesen halt braucht und das ist insofern
eine sammlung ist viel schlimmer als nur
eine
änderungen zum gesetzlichen definition
genau guter punkt kommt eine karte
bekommt weil sie noch mal eine eigene
kategorie einer ökonomischen theorie die
in gewisser weise eine qualitative
steigerung gegenüber dem nur schlechtes
dem unnützen nicht nur guter punkt da
gerät auch nicht nur das wesen der sache
in gefahr wie du völlig sachsen auch
unser verhältnis zum wesen in unserer
erkenntnis relation also wir werden da
total desorientiert wenn es keine form
mehr gibt haben wir keine ordnung mehr
wir verstehen die welt nicht mehr wir
verstehen die dinge ja nur aufgrund
ihres form aspekt also ist es dann so
eine art app systemischer super-gau
könnte man sagen es ist gut herr richtig
und diese klar geordnete welt muss
natürlich auch noch einen namen geben
und das wäre der kosmos
also es gibt die theorie und den kosmos
und sie kennen alle das griechische wort
oder das deutsche wort kosmetik kosmetik
ist der bereich der den schmuck betrifft
und kosmos heißt eigentlich ordnung und
schmuck das genau das selbe die ordnung
ist immer schön geordnet also die
ordnung ist gut und schön weil sie
ordnung ist und wenn die ordnung nicht
da ist weil die form fehlt ist es nicht
mehr schön wenn ich mir gut aber wie sie
richtig sagen nicht gleich irgendwie
moralisch müssen aber es geht dann
dorthin ist auf dieser spur
und alle fragen die menschen sich zu
einem der welt stecke campus um zu
erkennen und deswegen gefährlich
[Musik]
gefahren also beispiel flüge waren
überhaupt nicht problematisch
seine eigenschaft
insofern ist wunderbar wenn man habe ein
echtes problem ist die menschen rechnung
was schlecht hat gesagt sogar das böse
warum weil jeder der lähmung haben
werden
auch wenn menschen das ist natürlich
dieser loggien für hochproblematisch
das diesen wesen in seiner zelle
aktualität als mensch verloren geht
dadurch eine eigenschaften hat die nicht
zum menschsein passen das ist ein
riesengroßes otto logisches cw
oder der nennliste ganze ganze forscher
[Musik]
und das ist der historische aspekte
erwähnt hast also wird wir können nicht
erkennen wir können nicht mehr sagen und
es betrifft die ordnung des seins also
diese ohnehin begehbare einheit von
erkenntnistheoretische orientieren und
seien die wird dort irgendwie
durcheinander gebracht
ja ich glaube wir müssen es dabei
bewenden lassen es ist schon ein
bisschen über die zeit also wir haben
eigentlich den wichtigsten punkt jetzt
diskutiert es geht immer um das streben
zum guten zum seien und wo darin das
böse sei es nur als mahnung physikum
oder wie auch immer oder als böse
moralischen sinne ist ein ort hat und
ich glaube sie haben ganz richtig darauf
hingewiesen dass das moralisch böse im
heutigen sinne hier etwas wenig zum
vorschein tritt und wir ganz konkret
fragen müssen wie sieht es dann mit
bösen akten bösen handlungen aus wir
können uns die konkret vorstellen wir
werden der nächsten sitzung noch einmal
ganz kurz auf ein paar zitate zu
sprechen kommen und dann aber in der
dann aber vor allem uns mit luthers in
theorie befassen und ist die referentin
dieser nächsten sitzung auch hier genau
wir werden dann mit kurzes referat hören
ich glaube zu luthers reformatorische
einsicht nicht haben es glaube ich
eingetragen oder sonst ganz allgemein
gibt
alles klar dann bis zur nächsten sitzung